I'll I'll go right away and I I'll
explain I put the how Zaki film on here
because the more I like like sit Yeah
the more I sit after watching this movie
The More I really [__] with it I still
need to watch it yeah initially when I
left the theater I was kind of like okay
whatever but the more I've just gone on
about my life The more I've thought
about that movie a lot more which I feel
like a lot of movies don't do a lot of a
lot of movies when I watch them I
consume them and I think nothing of them
until someone reminds me they exist yeah
but this is one that I keep thinking
about
um I don't know what that that that says
about the movie but it's really stuck
with me what what are you thinking about
it I don't know I I I was really really
really and I know this is such a uh
usual thing to say but the music and the
visuals were so [__] good as always
yeah um well that's something you can
normally expect from a gibli film yeah I
know um Joe he says you don't miss me he
just doesn't [__] can you just be bad at
something I hate how talented he is and
it's and it's and it's annoying cuz I
really really don't enjoy hamaki as a
person as much uh just well just because
of the way that he kind of the way he
talks about things and it's dude I'm
still angry about how he was mean to his
son even even though some people online
online find that like really funny and
Bast like so [__] Bast and it's like
what a [__] awful Dad yeah but uh but
godamn he makes bangers God damn this
film is really [__] good and I and I
really can't wait to watch this dubbed
again cuz [__] Robert Patterson
he just it just looked like he he just
you know was in Twilight once and took
it personally and now he's just he's on
a mission to be good in everything ever
uh so super stoked about it but honestly
I I I I haven't watched many gibl films
but it's definitely my favorite one out
of all of them I like this more than
Spirited Away wow really um but then
again I didn't grow up with Spirited
Away I watched it for the first time
this year as well yeah uh you did yeah I
didn't know that yeah if I if I ever
said that I watched it before I lied cuz
I was self-conscious about not watching
it uh but I have now watched it wait so
what did you okay now I'm curious as
someone who just discovered Spirit of
away in 2023 what did you think of it I
enjoyed it as it asual um I thought it
was good I felt that because there was
so many uh so many visual metaphors and
a lot of different kind of uh what's the
word for this I forgot how to explain
this cuz my English explanations are bad
um a lot of different messages and
themes that I couldn't pick up on on my
first viewing that I I then had to like
when I read more about the movie and I
realized I missed a bunch of things cuz
there just so much going on especially
like visually there's just like they
would I I would read about the what each
visual representation meant and I was
like oh [__] I had no way of figuring
that out my first watch yeah yeah yeah
and you know I appreciated that but at
the same time I felt like I really
enjoyed the boy and the Heron uh I also
went into it knowing [__] nothing I
saided everyone in Japan yeah well we
did not have any marketing for you all I
know is that they had that one sick
sketch of the bird yeah and I was kind
of like all right let's find out um and
also I won't lie for me personally it
was really fun and satisfying getting to
watch film in Japanese uh and
understanding the entire plot H yeah I
was super stoked about that and I felt
like the only character I couldn't
understand was the bird sometimes
because you'd be
like and he taught really fast I like
hold on okay let me try and like back up
real quick but everyone else I could
understand pretty well and I was really
hyped about it and honestly it was a fun
time I I really want to rewatch it again
just so I can kind of articulate how I
feel about it much better but it really
really stuck with me and I feel like
that deserves something no a damn it's
the one Japanese film that's just not in
cinemas anymore I guess yeah right yeah
and you know and I think back to other
films I've watched this year and I think
I enjoyed Oppenheimer more which is why
it's on this list as well and I wanted
to put one movie on this list and up
putting two but opheim was probably and
I feel so bad putting it up there cuz
it's like feels like such a cop out no I
mean I watched Oppenheimer as well it
was [__] fantastic it is a great film
John Wick four came out this year which
I also loved yeah I was surprised you
didn't put John Wick on here which was I
feel like I've watched I've watched at
least every like nearly I want to say
80% of the theatrical releases of
English films in Japan right um and I've
been trying to watch almost every film
that's coming out did come out in Japan
it didn't I watched it in LA but it's
coming out this it's coming out in 2024
oh it is finally I thought they were
just never going to release so it is
coming out and I there's a lot of other
movies that didn't get theatrical that
have been really highly rated and I
really want to watch but in terms of
theatrical releases this is the one I
probably enjoyed most it does help that
I also watched in like the [__] best
theater I've ever been in in my life um
it was just a good film and agree I just
wish that we could I could somehow pause
a film and go piss in the theater
because I I had to I had to like
tactically think about when to piss yeah
and that's the only bad thing about it
but other than that you know it was such
a [__] good film that's why like when
I'm in the Cinemas I don't drink a
single drop of water so by the end of
the film just
like craft beers and I oh you they had
craft beers in it was craft beers food I
was I got wings I got bottomless popcorn
bro only in America man so I'm telling
you Oppenheimer was the one film where I
I I wanted like an eight course meal
during it I was the only [__] in
that whole theater eating and I I'd chew
into the salery it was and it would make
like a bone crunching sound it was so
[__] good eating eating a juicy ass
buffalo chicken wing when he's talking
to Einstein it was like this is what
life was meant to be I I still love how
hype I got you how how hype people get
when you just see Einstein yeah I know
why it was kind
of and I I watched Barbie as well and uh
there was the whole you know Barbie
versus op but I thought op I still
hadn't watched Barbie it's fun it's a
really good fil Barbie's more political
cool than Oppenheimer is that's what I
heard a weird way I heard that was a
meme I know how true it is actually but
it's like dude it's it's crazy how you
know you know and we you when we head to
S we talk about one piece we were like w
one piece is political and obviously we
played it up a bit and people were like
Ming on us like we didn't we didn't know
one piece of political obviously I know
that one piece is political but I was
you know I think all of us were like
playing it up to kind of H have the
conversation enter that kind of thing
and there are a lot of media that are
very very political the people um uh and
and I guess I'll talk about this when we
talk about Final Fantasy but like I I've
because I played FY that people talk
about the new one they're like man I
hope they don't get political about it
and I'm like the whole game is super
political the whole series is political
and so many so much media is super
political inherently because of the
themes they're tackling and people like
they just ignore it cuz it's not what
they want to deal with but I felt like
Bobby people were like man I just don't
like political it's like oh [__] off you
watch so much political [__] but
suddenly when it's about a topic that
makes you slightly uncomfortable it's
too political literally every Final
Fantasy is Big military organization
takes over corrupt religious
organization so many game so many games
so much media you consume is way more
political that people like to admit but
the moment it's about some a kind of
politics that they kind of really don't
want to be don't want to be faced with
that's when they start being like and I
thought bobie uh unfortunately was one
of those where it was like yeah well I
think I think there's this goes like two
to play Devil's Advocate a lot of people
would just want to watch media for like
to escape the ab to to as escapism to
escape the live they're living right now
and obviously there are a lot of
different political things and pretty
much baked into every single piece of
media that you consume but some stories
might hit a little too close to home oh
than other stories I think the most like
recent one I can think of that I watched
recently was you know you watch Pluto
right yeah the one where they uh had a
whole storyline about going to this
Middle Eastern
country to look for uh robots of mass
destruction that may or may not have
been in
development was a little I was like I
was like H okay we couldn't have we
couldn't have thought of a slightly
different story like that I was I was
like I I I have no doubt this is not
inspired by real events at all or real
politics you know yeah and I think
that's why one piece and like Final
Fantasy do really well is that there the
messages are real but they're not
grounded in anything that you can like
be like oh they're talking about this
they're also more generalized right so
it's harder to like pinpoint like oh
they're referencing this particular
thing and the only thing I can probably
in that sense that the people didn't
like about bobie it's probably because
bobie sometimes would just straight up
talk to you about what it was trying to
tell you which I think is it's still on
the nose it's it's and also you know I
felt like the message was getting across
anyway sometimes without needing to tell
people I think the moment you're telling
the audience hey this is the problem
hey this is the politics talking about
it's like okay well fig that out myself
yeah I I think I think it's inherently
what the messes and how you portray that
message some some some pieces of media
do it really well like you know
sometimes the best the best ones are
shows like South Park or Always Sunny
where they kind of don't lean towards
one message or another they're more of
just like making you think about the
entire
situation yeah in itself so I thought
was interesting
South Fox sometimes okay and sometimes
really [__] bad depending on what
they want to do but it is very funny
seeing people be like look Eric
Cartman's right guys he was right all
along everything is two o and it's like
do you understand who Eric kman is and
what the role he fills you are
completely missing the point you are the
the fact that you're taking things agree
with Eric means you're wrong